[Music]
Revolutionizing farming. 10 incredible
agricultural machines you need to see.
Agriculture is no longer just about hard
labor and manual tools. Today, advanced
machines are taking over. Want to see
farming at a whole new level? Let's dive
into the most innovative machinery that
is transforming farms worldwide. Welcome
to the world of modern agriculture,
where technology is making farming
faster, easier, and more efficient. In
this video, top benefits of agricultural
machinery presents a fascinating
collection of machines that are
completely changing the farming
landscape. From harvesting crops to
planting trees, these machines do it
all, and they do it with ease. Let's
explore these farming marvels. The Milp
put loader. Imagine collecting raw soil
effortlessly. This machine uses a wide
scoop and a flexible conveyor belt to
move soil with incredible speed and
accuracy, saving farmers valuable time.
Leaf stripper. Before apple harvest
season, the leaf stripper comes to the
rescue. Equipped with a dual adjustable
air system, it blows away leaves,
providing clear visibility during
sorting. H Stackand 60. Ever wondered
how massive grass blocks are made? This
machine acts like a vacuum cleaner,
sucking up debris and compressing it
into perfect shapes.
ASAT to keep pastures fresh and healthy.
The EA6O airator works wonders, ensuring
the soil gets the air it needs without
damaging the surface. Gruber SM650
manure spreader. Spreading manure across
hilly fields is no challenge for this
top tier machine. Designed for maximum
efficiency. CLASS Lexion Combine
Harvester with its 9.3 m wide cutting
platform. This harvester brings speed
and precision to sunflower and other
crop harvesting. Poultrybot. Collecting
eggs just got easier. Thanks to
proximity sensors and a laser scanner,
this robot picks eggs without disturbing
the hens. Mamba conservation tool. In
difficult terrains, the Mamba
efficiently collects rare plants, making
conservation work much easier and safer.
Etera Vortex Grinder. Removing tree
stumps has never been easier. This
machine grinds stumps down to the ground
with incredible speed. Ley Astronaut A5.
Revolutionizing the dairy industry. This
automated milking system ensures cows
are milked with comfort, boosting their
productivity. From reducing labor costs
to maximizing efficiency, these machines
are paving the way for the future of
farming. Which one would you want on
your farm? Let us know in the comments
below. If you enjoyed this video and
want to see more cuttingedge
agricultural tech, hit that like button,
subscribe to our channel, and don't
forget to comment on your favorite
machine. Stay tuned for more amazing
farming innovations.